dr. Charles Kesler he is the dangler die
coma distinguished professor of
government at Claremont McKenna
Institute and he is also the editor of
The Claremont Review of Books he is the
co-editor of keeping the tablets modern
American conservative thought with
William F Buckley Jr and as dr.
Spaulding just mentioned his new book I
am the change barack obama and the
future of liberalism is now out in
paperback
so please would you all give a warm
welcome for dr. Charles Kesler
thank you very much that kind
introduction thank you ladies and
gentlemen for being here today my the
paperback version of my book appeared on
October the 1st the day that the federal
government shut down I thought that was
pretty good for a paperback what I want
to talk about today is is sort of the
fate of the Tea Party or the the future
relationship between the Tea Party
movement and the American conservative
movement broadly considered I was not in
Washington when the epic battles of the
last few weeks were fought so I don't
have any first-hand knowledge or insider
information which is always useful to
have in Washington talks and if you want
to know what the Tea Party leaders were
thinking in the in the late struggles my
standard answer is I wish they knew but
I will have some some criticisms of
tactics but I'm more interested really
in the larger overarching theme of of
the fate of the Tea Party because I
think it is very valuable it's the most
encouraging thing to happen to
conservatism in a long time to think
that amid all the economic disorder
following from the Great Recession that
the only real populist movement to
emerge would be one from the right that
would be the Tea Party and not only a
right-wing populist movement but a
constitutionalist one one that's calling
for a not only a revival of popular
government but of constitutional
government at the same time is really
quite remarkable one would have
predicted one would have thought at
least that the populist outrage would be
primarily from the left and that this
would be another moment like the 1930s
when you would you would hear a renewed
call for various forms of big government
liberalism and even socialist economics
but the fall of the Soviet Union took so
much wind out of the sails of the
socialist international that there
really was there wasn't the kind of
popular grassroots left-wing reaction
that many people were predicting at any
rate well let me begin by saying
something about the namesake of the Tea
Party movement it's named after of
course the famous event in late 1773
when many cases of tea were
unceremoniously dumped into the harbor
at Boston that was a one-night stand it
was not a popular movement it was not an
organization designed to last it was not
the beginning of a political party it
was a it was a more or less carefully
orchestrated strike against the the tea
which was being taxed and sold by or by
the monopoly provider the East India
Company which the Sons of Liberty the
ongoing organization in Boston had
actually arranged apparently for the tea
party to take place but the tea party
itself was just that it was that an act
of civil disobedience and a very careful
act of civil disobedience you know if
you look at the history of the Tea Party
itself you find that they were very
cautious not to harm or or to spoil any
actual private property on board the tea
ships that whose tea they were
unceremoniously dumping into the harbor
only the tea only the the cause of the
grievance was harmed it was a very
carefully moderated and thoughtful act
you might say of civil disobedience our
Tea Party seems to be more than that it
purports to be more than that it wants
to be a part of conservatism maybe it
wants to be the major part of
conservatism it wants to be some sort of
ongoing if not organization then at
least some sort of ongoing movement and
exactly how one becomes an
movement without succumbing to and
becoming as an organization or a cluster
of organizations with narrower interests
of course is one of the things one of
the major questions to ask about the
future of the Tea Party movement but so
far I would say that judging them as
political doctors as it were that the
Tea Party has been absolutely right in
its diagnosis of the problems facing
American government and American
conservatism but somewhat wrong in its
prescriptions and I think you you might
say it needs to work on its bedside
manner as well but I think that may come
with time to begin with when I say it's
correct in its diagnosis I think the one
thing that all of the tea party senators
and congressmen have in common is the
very strong sense that Obamacare is not
just another piece of legislation it's
not just another costly bureaucratic
top-down regulatory scheme of which we
have alas so many but there's something
genuinely tyrannical about this piece of
legislation that it threatens not only
to spoil our medical care system but
indirectly and directly and sooner as
well as later to begin to subvert our
form of government and our way of life
it's true that in some respects it is
just one more big federal regulatory
scheme or medical care scheme but even
if it's an incremental addition you know
sometimes one reaches a tipping point by
way of incremental addition additions
and I think the Tea Party is right
exactly right to fear that Obamacare if
allowed to remain in place would
eventually fundamentally change the
relation between citizens and
governments in this country it is it's
not only its its effects as a policy but
its effects on our character our
expectations of government how we will
approach governments in the future that
that seems to me to be its fundamental
consequences and is fundamentally bad
consequences and one I think that one in
a certain sense Obamacare brings out the
worst in liberals it brings out their
most characteristic passions and
commitments and once you see those in
view once you see how they responded to
the Tea Party and to the attempt to
repeal Obamacare you learn a lot about
why Obamacare itself is so dangerous for
American politics let let's begin with
the with the fact I think that for
liberals that the liberal impatience
with partisanship with people who object
to their plans who resist their plans
arises from the fact that in liberalism
there's no right of revolution now that
may seem like a strange thing to say but
if you think about it I think it's it
turns out to be true
if one looks at some of the political
theorists who were most important to
liberalism couldn't I mean by this
modern liberalism status liberalism if
you look if you think of Hegel or Kant
in Germany if you think of Woodrow
Wilson here at home they're all quite
explicit that there's no such thing as a
right of revolution the people people
always gets and has the government it
deserves and in a certain way the
government it needs and in any case one
could not universalize the the notion of
a right of revolution without destroying
the conditions of law itself and so for
liberals there's no right of
fundamentally overturning liberalism
itself liberalism is our government our
establishment these days and there's as
they like to say no turning back the
clock and so the Tea Party presents
itself to liberals as itself an
absurdity because the tea party recalls
a revolution the American Revolution and
the implication is it might not be such
a bad thing to have another one to have
a second installment at least of the
spirits of the American Revolution to
get rid
so much excessive government and so much
of government that is harmful to
American prosperity and to American
character that notion that you could
that there's something beyond big
government that there's an alternative
to big government that is real that is
that it might be possible to revolve
back to to liberalism
is absurd and even impious I'd say
and so liberals become very impatient
when conservatives refused to conserve
liberalism this is the position of most
notably of sam Tanenhaus formerly the
editor of the New York Times Book Review
and the the author of a book the death
of conservatism which you may have seen
a few years ago it came out just as the
Tea Party ignited in 2010 and threw out
a lot of Democrats but tannin houses
view is that conservatism is good
insofar as it consolidates and preserves
the liberal order if conservatism turns
revolutionary or if it wants to
overthrow the liberal order or rollback
the liberal order then it exceeds its
commission then it goes off the
reservation so to speak because from
liberalism's point of view liberalism is
progress and progress is forever Park
progress is final
Obama said this a few years ago in when
he was trying to pass his signature
health care bill that he recognized he
wasn't the last president to strive for
some form of national he wasn't the
first president sorry to strife or some
form of national health care but he
intended to be the last and that meant
after you once you have it you'll never
get rid of it
and he will be the president who finally
brings us the the joys of Obamacare and
the joys of a truly national health care
system what we had before Medicare was
only was basically for older people
Medicaid for poor people but we had no
system that was
truly Universal for that established a
right to health care for everyone and
once that was established once he had
succeeded that was it America will have
this forever there's no going back but
of course the Tea Party in its name and
in its politics threatens to go back it
threatens to go back might not be the
right term to go forward to go beyond
big government top-down 1930s style
bureaucratic liberalism but there is
nothing beyond big government for for
liberals Bill Clinton famously said in
1996 the era of big government is over
but he never meant big government was
over he meant only that the era of its
establishment or maybe its rapid its
most rapid growth was behind it but
there was nothing beyond big government
except maybe bigger government and
that's the way all liberals look at it
this is part of the final solution to
the human problem it's part of the you
know the the end of history in something
like the Hegelian sense or the sense
that Frank Fukuyama made his reputation
twenty or so years ago by talking about
almost thirty years ago I guess now so
the Tea Party by recalling revolution in
both senses of the term recalling
strikes liberals is absolutely insane I
mean bonkers just completely unaware of
its surrounding refusing to adjust to
its environment not playing well with
others and Tanenhaus this is the last
time I'll refer to him Tanenhaus echoes
this analysis he says that the death of
conservatism comes when it ceases to be
Burkean and becomes Jacobin and from
Tannen House's point of view resistance
to big government is Jacobin ISM it's
it's it's being a French revolutionary
as opposed to being an opponent of the
French Revolution it is to oppose big
government is to appeal to universal and
abstract principles like the rights of
man are like natural right
and Tanenhaus rejects natural rights in
that sense as firmly as John C Calhoun
did one of his one of the favorite
people to whom he likes to compare
conservatives but in fact there's a lot
in his own analysis that suggests a
certain kind of good-natured calhoune
ISM conservatism especially of the tea
party variety threatens the liberal
ancien régime it threatens the
establishment it threatens what we call
big government now you have to say that
the Left overcame conservative
opposition narrowly when it passed
Obamacare but the victory itself was so
strained so narrow that it suggests at
least to me perhaps signs of liberal
overextension of liberals having come to
and cross the bridge too far the fact
that it was passed by party line vote I
mean really by party line vote on the
question is large and momentous as this
with rampant side deals to buy out all
complicating interest groups and pass
with against great resistance and
resentment which has not gone away I
mean we remember how it was passed we
remembered the illegitimate see in the
larger sense of of the partisan and
intent and corrupt or crony way it was
shoved through and then of course the
latest faceplant with the way Obama
cares exchange has rolled out and the
the the web page for it all of these
things suggest a certain hubris on the
part of liberals and that the Tea Party
was born to be the Nemesis of this last
perhaps exhausting and maybe a truly
final victory of over extended
liberalism and above all in light of
that kind of victory that the tea
party is tired of losing its tired of
the conservative movements highest
function being to slow down the growth
of big government it wants to win it
wants to reverse the growth of big
government or at least to bring back
some form of constitutional limitations
upon upon the way we govern ourselves it
wants to turn the tide and again that
that makes it revolutionary from the
point of view of liberalism and the the
question is to what extent it makes it
revolutionary from the point of view of
conservatism and I think maybe on that
count there's some truth to its claims
but it may be they're slightly
overstated but the Tea Party and here
comes here comes my generic criticism of
them but the Tea Party needed a strategy
for constitutional renewal that it so
far has conspicuously lacked a strategy
that would have allowed it to choose the
tactics to match its ends thinking
through a strategy would also have
clarified those ends what is it exactly
that the Tea Party meant by limited
government limited to what and limited
by what clearly the Tea Party's form of
conservatism prescribed or presupposed
revolving back or rotating back to the
Constitution as the basis for restoring
limited governments and this was the the
deep project that underlies its desire
to repeal Obamacare or to defund
Obamacare and it was this larger project
of returning to the Constitution that
not the government shutdown or the
refusal to pass a clean debt ceiling
increase and so forth that the Obama
administration and other liberals
regarded as the Republicans most
dangerous obsession and this obsession
they love to call dysfunctional so did
their academic allies like Norm Ornstein
it's one of his favorite words the
attempt to to get rid of Obamacare
in general to return to the old
Constitution is dysfunctional any form
of partisan resistance to the the next
inevitable wave of liberalism recalls
the old Constitution and its separation
of powers its spirit of checks and
balances and the new liberalism is
intolerant of that when they say that
Obamacare and the Tea Party in general
is dysfunctional they mean dysfunctional
to their Constitution the living
Constitution from a conservative point
of view it was the passage of Obamacare
not its repeal that was dysfunctional
because it represented a sort of
breakdown of constitutional governments
even though one could argue that it it
was legal certainly although there are
there are some side issues there that
would need would need discussion still
the overall spirit of that piece of
legislation was unconstitutional and the
way past partook of that of cutting
corners and of you know a new spirit a
new kind of Constitution for our
governments the Tea Party concluded from
the way that Obamacare squeaked by and
was imposed on an unwilling basically an
unwilling people that what we are seeing
these days is really two not two
conflicting interpretations of the same
Constitution between liberals and
conservatives but really two different
constitutions in conflict the old
constitution of 1787 on the one hand and
the living Constitution on the other and
I think there's something to this notion
that the more one thinks about the
living Constitution the more one
realizes it's not just an approach to
the interpretation of the original
Constitution but an alternative to the
original Constitution we can say maybe
something more about that in the
question period and the extraordinary
partisanship the extraordinary fight the
Tea Party was willing to put up or to
launch arose from this fact that the
stakes in the Obamacare battle were
very high amounting almost to a regime
choice to two different ways of
government that were having it out in
this colossal fight the Tea Party and I
think President Obama both understood
this very clearly the the mainstream a
GOP less so with much less clarity and
intensity now the the failure of the
Roberts Court to strike down Obamacare
and the individual mandate played into
the Tea Party's sense of this being a
kind of constitutional moment the the
court after all had come close to
striking down the whole Act there were
five votes to rule it unconstitutional
under the Commerce Clause before John
Roberts changed the subject to the
taxing clause so we came closer than we
might realize today to winning that
fight then we have Randy Barnett Sahu is
key player in mounting that fight in the
audience very honored to have him here
the senators and congressmen from the
Tea Party who were elected in 2012 I
think concluded that the old
Constitution judicial review the
separation of powers the all those
mechanisms you learned about in in grade
school did not seem capable of defending
the Constitution against this
fundamental challenge the court punted
on the the main question allowed
Obamacare to become law and even though
I would I would hasten to say we haven't
seen the last court challenge to
Obamacare there is there will be a kind
of guerrilla warfare in the courts going
on for a long time to come so long as
Obamacare is still the law and some of
those new challenges may very well
succeed but still I think it was a
revealing moment to the the new senators
elected in 2012 and congressmen as well
that suggested that if anyone was going
to save us from Obamacare it was not
going to be the court or the old
Constitution and it's and its offices
and institutions but the American people
themselves this required a kind of
recked appealed back to the the public
to the source of authority for any
constitution in the country Roberts's
about-face in that decision graphically
revealed the the failure of the
establishment and including the
establishment republican republicans who
nominated and and and backed him and
also perhaps the treachery of the
establishment to have made chief justice
a man who refused to follow the argument
where it led or was who - who was not
courageous enough to do what was
necessary to kill Obamacare when the
opportunity presented itself those
judgments I think are probably unfair or
at least they're not completely true but
their conclusion the tea party's
conclusion was now it's up to the people
and it's up to us to raise the
consciousness of the people about this
constitutional moment this revolutionary
threat that faced us and hence we come
to it seems to me something fundamental
about the Tea Party it's unusual
character it is a populist movement to
defend a constitution and a way of life
based upon that Constitution but the
Constitution is meant among other things
to limit populism
in our politics and so you have this
seeming paradox of a populist movement
to save something that is not itself a
populist document but is designed to
channel and moderate popular passion
into constitutional forms into office
wholly you know into elections and and
the whole process of our self-government
it was incumbent on the tea party above
all then to try to keep its populism in
line with its constitutionalism to keep
its means in line with its end of
reviving constitutional government in
the midst of a fight of course it's
often the case that you'll use any stick
to beat a mad dog
with and so the Tea Party seized upon
the continuing resolution to try to
entrap Obamacare rather than attack it
directly which they didn't have the
votes to do in the legislature to entrap
it in another issue that might allow
them if not to bring it down at least to
defund it for the time being the choice
of the CR the you know the continuing
resolution was not as arbitrary or
mischievous as it might first appear and
as many of the mainstream GOP members
thought because congressional
resolutions are themselves abdications
of the Congress's own budget process and
derelictions you might say of
constitutional duty to protect the
public purse and to oversee the massive
amounts of government spending that they
are authorizing so the spirit of the CR
was akin to Obamacare from the point of
view of the tea party it too was a kind
of insult to the Constitution and to
ordinary legislative processes under the
Constitution but to fight the CR and the
debt ceiling battles and the Obamacare
battle all at once was taking on a lot
and it seems to me that it it's not a
complete failure but it was far from
being a success and the Republican
leaders the mainstream part of the party
let's say warned the tea partiers about
this where were the votes going to come
from to defund Obamacare not in the
house but in the Senate and of course
what about Obama and his veto pen and
senator Cruz and company could never
answer that question they didn't have a
tactic they didn't have a strategy
exactly they certainly didn't have the
tactics necessary to make a strategy
work so what were they thinking
apparently the hope was that Obama fresh
from reelection by a comfortable
majority of the popular vote and a
sizeable majority of the electoral vote
would cave when the moment came or that
an outright
American public fresh from reelecting
Obama and the Democratic Senate with two
more Democrats than were there before
would rise up and put such pressure on
Senate Democrats that they would fold
and vote to defund the program that
their party had been longing for since
Franklin Roosevelt or maybe that both
would happen at the same time in
expecting Obama and the Senate Democrats
to give in if they truly did expect that
the tea party showed I'd say it's own
populist brand of impatience with the
separation of powers and bicameralism
and the legislative process that we have
set up in this country in imagining that
the American public could be inspired
persuaded or goaded to in effect
reconsider the results of the just held
election the tea party the Tea Partiers
surrendered in my judgment to their own
version of the leadership theory that
liberals have long preferred to
legislative executive politics of the
old constitutional sort the implicit
argument I suppose was that the tea
party mandate that is going over the
heads of party leaders and
constitutional office holders to appeal
directly to the people and urging the
people to put pressure on their
representatives that that new mandate
would trump the mandate just awarded in
the election now I have to say that this
is it not this is a time-honored tactic
Ronald Reagan was famous for going over
the heads of legislators and you know
his famous saying was if you can't make
them see the light you can at least make
them feel the heat and and but that's a
the origin of this tactic is really with
Woodrow Wilson so even though
conservatives have used it it has us it
has a slight presumption against it but
still Reagan had been able to use it
many times for good causes but he did it
of course from the bully pulpit of the
presidency not from the Senate floor and
one could not have expected it seems to
me a speech no matter how impassioned
and cogent from the Senate floor to have
the same effect
we learned from Newt Gingrich that it
really is very difficult to run American
government from a house of the
legislature where you you know Newt
Gingrich only represented four hundred
thousand or however many constituents a
district had in those days and strictly
speaking Ted Cruz represented only the
people of Texas and so you know it's
whereas the president is one of one not
one of a hundred and represents in some
sense the whole people it's just a lot
easier to to engage an issue
rhetorically and popularly from the
presidency than from the legislature so
as the these unreasonable hopes faded
the Tea Party caucus had to settle for
less and less delaying the individual
mandate rather than defunding it
verifying the subsidies of policyholders
in the insurance exchanges abolishing
the medical devices tax delaying the
medical devices tax they they were
pushed back and back to less and less of
course this this is not exactly to blame
them this means that their colleagues
were not supporting them but I blame the
presumption that their colleagues would
support them under these circumstances
all of these things were reasonable
goals but each was confirmation that the
slumbering public had not been roused by
Senator Cruz's oratory or anybody else's
and that the public was not riding
toward the sound of the guns now to
summarize the Tea Party I think was
right absolutely right
about the potential evils of an actual
evils of Obamacare and the perils of the
Liberals increasingly brazen assaults on
the Constitution including President
Obama's asserted prerogatives to choose
which laws to enforce and to make recess
appointments when there was no recess
and Ted Cruz and the Tea Partiers
deserve a lot of praise on this ground
they they have made the Obama care they
kept the Obama care issue alive and they
have put it in a place of prominence
that it will be very difficult for any
Republican to run away from it seems to
me but the establishment Republicans
were right about
the outcome of the effort to defund
Obamacare by tying it to the CR so it
seems in a way that these two groups
need each other not only in the sense
that you need both of them to get to a
majority in the House of Representatives
even but at least for the time being in
the sense that of supplying each other's
defects or curing each other's excesses
it's neither wise nor moderate to treat
fellow party members as thoroughgoing
political enemies and both sides were
guilty of that both sides are necessary
parts of a party and either side is
going to go away conservatives have
always have always had trouble with
moderate or liberal Republicans whether
you call them Eastern establishment
Republicans like in the 50s and 60s or
you call them country club Republicans
as maybe in the 70s and 80s but the fact
is the coalition that the Republicans
need requires both of those groups in
addition to some others so it would be
good to learn to live with them and to
educate one another in the in the best
way possible so here and just for the
last few minutes I want to say something
about where we go from here and how the
Tea Party could do itself and the
Republican Party and the country a great
service by working out what a return to
constitutional government might really
mean and thus the strategy and tactics
appropriate to it
there example could help make the
exploration and defense of the
Constitution it's letter and it's
spirits an essential part of the new
conservatism you in a way I'm calling
for less populism and more politics more
political thinking on the part of the
tea party constitutional thinking is in
some ways the highest form of political
thinking and the two will go together
the two are not opposed putting together
a majority and defending the
Constitution are not opposed to each
other they are in fact implicit in each
other they imply each other and it's
only if the tea party
and the Republicans can sort of
understand how to do both at the same
time that will be successful in a way
that deserves to be successful for after
a century of progressive mining and
sapping of the Constitution the great
document we count on to defend us now
needs our defense and the form of
government we count on to embody the
Constitution's principles now is itself
in need of significant restoration and
renewal let me give a few examples of
how to bring the spirit of the
Constitution and the spirit of
conservatism closer together we could
start with the judiciary of course
senators Cruz and Mike Lee are already
eloquent I've heard them both give
extended discourses on the subject on
the point that the Constitution does not
make the court the final arbiter of
constitutional meaning in any
comprehensive sense so I say let them
apply that insight to Obamacare the
problem with Obamacare as I was saying
before is not merely that it will ruin
health care but that it undermines the
whole nation the whole notion of rights
natural rights that come not from
government but from our own nature and
God and more generally it corrupts
American government and character a few
days ago in the Wall Street Journal Jim
DeMint presiding across the street here
at Heritage attacked Obamacare as quote
unfair unworkable and unaffordable which
is pretty good but that leaves the
constitution of the nation and of our
private character out of the picture so
when denouncing Obamacare let's hear
more about the unconstitutional aspects
of the whole and of its parts the the
fattest target is probably the IPAB the
Independent Payment Advisory Board which
if I may quote myself
is is almost it's unconstitutional on
its face when we think it's it's 15
members appointed by the president would
make recommendations to limit Medicare's
budget by reducing reimbursements to
doctors unless both houses of Congress
overrule it by passing their own equal
or greater cuts to Medicare I PABs
proposals will automatically become law
as the 15 unelected people what's worse
the act conspires to make IPAB permanent
and get this by mandating that no
resolution to repeal it can be
introduced and into the legislature
until January 1st 2017 nor can any such
repeal motion be introduced after
February 1st 2017 in other words the
Constitution would be operational for
one month only and even then the repeal
any repeal must pass by August 15 2017
to be valid and could not take effect
until 2020 now Congress could presumably
unravel these restrictions and undo IPAB
any time it wanted to but nonetheless
the spirit of that law with a letter and
the spirit of that regulation suggest
just how averse and adverse to the old
Constitution Obamacare really is I mean
to think that you couldn't repeal it
except for one month and then it
wouldn't take effect for three years
afterwards is astounding to me why don't
we talk more about that in condemning
Obamacare I mean a power grab like that
if the American I think the I mean the
American people would be interested in
and how they lose their own liberties it
seems to me but they're they won't be
interested if we don't interest them in
it if we don't hit that note and of
course there are many other forms of
delegated legislation
authority to the Secretary of HHS and to
the hundreds of boards and agency
agencies she's empowered to create and
not to mention the 20,000 and counting
pages of regulations written so far to
bring the 2,500 plus pages of the bill
itself to life now while we're at it
conservatives should be calling for
other kinds of reforms in order to apply
the consent of the governed to
regulations which form so much of the ma
of the substance of modern government
let's call for a vote by Congress on all
regulations costing $100,000 $100,000 or
more that's one idea already in
circulation or why not requiring the
appropriations committee or at least
some combination of committees and
chairmen in the legislature to approve
all regulations approved by every agency
so that there has to be some democratic
say-so before any any regulations can be
issued by any agency that doesn't
require change in the Constitution I I
think although we'd be resisted but it
seems to require only a change in the
law or a fight over that or requiring
Congress to follow its own budget rules
and formulate this this doesn't require
an amendment either I don't think it
just requires vigorous partisanship on
the part of Republicans you know why are
we stuck passing continuing resolutions
which effectively cede all positive
budgetary authority to the agencies and
to the regular unelected regulators
instead of insisting on 13
appropriations bills for the 13
departments which give both parties a
chance to get in there and and fight it
out and make what cuts we can make and
and to prioritize what is more
constitutional and more essential and
what is less and less essential many
people John Marini who's also in the
audience today Christopher DeMuth bill
Vogel II others have written
intelligently on just these kinds of
forms well short of constitutional
amendments that would help to
reinvigorate congressional
accountability and constitutional
government let conservatives use the
powers they have as constitutional
office holders to reinvigorate the
organs of self government's and to help
the Constitution to work again if we
don't start to correct these structural
deformations in our government and if we
don't enlighten the public about how it
is losing control of its own government
and its own constitution then no matter
how many good policies we enact or how
low we set the tax rates the body
politic will continue to sicken and
self-government will slip right through
our fingers the sobering thing is that
conservatives have really not tried a
constitutional agenda along side of the
sorta I'm calling for alongside a good
policy agenda for a long time the last
conservatives to really attempt such a
thing were pre New Deal conservatives
now we and since then American
conservatism has been less interested
than it should be it seems to me in the
health of the document that makes
self-government in America possible
those pre New Deal conservatives were
defeated alas by the New Deal we should
remember that we can learn from that and
I think we had better thank you very
much
and we have similar here with
microphones so over here first
Fred Fred Smith competitive enterprise
institute the progressive dismantling of
the Constitution is a story that we all
are painfully aware of I think I always
say that the Constitution like our human
documents isn't perfect but it is so
much better than what we have now but
the progresses did that by first merging
was sort of the tea party equivalency
agrarians and the Westerners but then
they did something that you didn't talk
about they also reached out and formed
effectively Baptists bootleggers
coalition's they've they you found
economic groups the unions particularly
but also trial lawyers more modernly
and two large segments of the of the
economic profession our movement seems
to be balkanized
the tea parties you pointed out here the
limousine Republicans and the
intellectuals really and also the
business community we seem to not have
failed to create the Alliance we need to
effectively defend the Constitution and
all our liberties well I wasn't really I
was taking off from the recent intra
Republican congressional conflicts
that's my excuse and I'm sticking to it
but if you if you're talking about the
political movement as a whole business
is absolutely indispensable to it I mean
not just and not just Chamber of
Commerce businesses but entrepreneurs
and and people who are in the lower
middle class and who are striving and
trying to build their own business I
mean one of the things about modern
liberalism is the attempt to
delegitimize business by arguing that
every businessman is is a selfish egoist
and that there's no virtue required only
good luck
to make a fortune or to make even a
product that's better than the
competitors products on the market one
of the great things about Reagan was in
he valorized as they say entrepreneurs I
mean he for the first time really since
the New Deal introduced the rhetorical
possibility of heroic a businessman who
were only risk takers they were
innovators they were they were people
who worked very hard fought very hard
fought very hard and they did they
deserve their success and they deserve
to be celebrated for the the benefits to
this society that their success and
example brought I by no means think we
should go take even one step backward
from his from Reagan's approach to the
question and to the extent that the
division between Tea Party and
establishment is itself a criticism of
business or at least big business or
Chamber of Commerce business I don't
think that's helpful and not only in
terms of the party's fortunes but also
for the country I mean there's a
difference between big business and
small business and entrepreneurs and and
those who are running establishments but
those differences are all secondary it
seems to me to the defense of private
property and the defense of the
capitalists virtues
hi Charles thanks for a great talk I
have two observations about the tea
party that I'd like to get your reaction
to the first is it has to do with the
importance of non acquiescence and one
of the things that our lawsuit did
successfully do notwithstanding the
unfortunate outcome that left Obamacare
standing is that it really kept the
Affordable Care Act in legitimacy limbo
for close to three years which allowed
time for the political action to bring
about a change in the house of Congress
changed in the house representatives
representative representation there as
well as the presidential campaign that
could have been fought over that issue
but wasn't very effectively done but it
was that non acquiescence that allowed
that to happen the what what's going to
change the fundamental small C
Constitution of the country is
acquiescence to this and that's the
reason why I would argue that what the
tea party contingent accomplished and it
was a good idea for them to oppose the
CR and they accomplished a very
significant thing in opposing the CR it
was because after the courts have
struggle has ended then all the @ non
acquiescence has to happen in the
political sphere and this is another
example of what has to be a continuing
series of examples of non acquiescence
and so even though it's was overwhelmed
by force or power it was clear the
record has been made that there was no
acquiescence and so I would say that in
if you look at it that way rather than
what you've won but what you've
continued to preserve which is not
acquiescence we not only that not only
is a good example of how to do it you
take your opportunities where you find
them but it actually worked in that
respect and we need more continuing on
until the political process can respond
adequately to actually literally repeal
the law so that's point number one about
the effectiveness of what the tea party
contingent did point number two is how
to view the tea party itself from from
those of us who work in the realm of
ideas in one form or another I don't
think it's right to think it one of
there's one sentence they probably the
only sentence in your whole talk I
disagreed with in which you sort of
asked the tea party to produce X I don't
think that's the right way of looking at
the tea party when I was a prosecutor
making arguments in front of juries I
didn't ask the jury to make my case for
me but I had to appeal to the jury in
to make my case I could not successfully
get what I wanted without the jury's
concurrence the Tea Party is the jury
they're not the intellectual
entrepreneurs they're the people to be
set that are up there conscious they're
aware they're in demand they're that
they're the market you know the the the
the market for Apple products it does
not create the iPhone right Apple
creates the iPhone to satisfy the market
the tea party is the relevant market
it's up to the entrepreneurs the
intellectual entrepreneurs who aren't
all that entrepreneurial necessarily to
actually appeal to that market and
they're not doing if I can all tenured
the insect so sort of the the inside the
beltway intellectuals are not appealing
to that market they when I go around and
and I'm and I'm in private conversations
with folks here not here but I mean in
this town I hear you know bitching and
carping and moaning and condescension
towards these unwashed people and that's
the wrong attitude you are if you're
going to be the leaders you have to
appeal to them they're the jury and so
they will decide whether your ideas are
right but it's up to you to come up with
the ideas and so I think that we have to
realize there's a division of labor in
the Liberty movement and it's unfair to
ask the jury to produce the case to be
prosecuted I thought you were a member
of the Tea Party yes well let's say I
met the in the extended sense yeah hard
to rate I mean mark Levin for example is
somebody who speaks directly the tea
party has a book called the Liberty
amendments in which he's making a
proposal he's a talk radio guy he's very
smart he's a lawyer he used to be in the
Republican in the Reagan administration
in the Justice Department he's no slouch
but you know in in you know in the
circles that people run in you don't
talk about Mark Levin all that much
you're not supposed to because he's Mark
Levin right but I mean the idea is if
you don't like what Mark Levin is doing
where are the alternatives of people
speaking directly the tea parties saying
here here's what you guys ought to do
that's what I think we're lacking sorry
right no no I mean you in a way you the
second point echoes the point I was
making at the beginning that the the
original tea party was a sort of
populist
though orchestrated and movement but it
wasn't the it didn't create the American
Revolution it wasn't you know it was Sam
Adams not John Adams it was you know
there had to be there had to be a kind
of intellectual leadership but and that
III acknowledge and I only I guess I
know why I'm calling for the Tea Party
to be open to that and then but they
can't supply themselves that's certainly
true in an extended sense those who
advise the Tea Party can be called Tea
Partiers I guess and in that sense it
was in essence that I addressed them as
I did on the first point I think I agree
with that and the the illegitimate
barrier is is essential to this fight no
doubt no doubt about that
but one would hope that in the future
the fights we we blunder into and
especially those we get to choose will
be ones that don't divide our party and
unite the other party but ones that
divide the other party and unite our
party broadly speaking I think
thank you for your remarks I I agree
with them
the Republicans and some of them have
been very outspoken and criticizing the
Tea Party and I often think and I'd like
your observation on this what would
happen if the Democrats suddenly had had
this upwelling of people across the
country who had close to 700,000 march
on Washington they had cells if you will
all over the country telling the
Democrat Party we have your back I think
that the Democrats would not have
criticized the Tea Party I think they
would have used him as a battering ram
to tell the country look at where the
people are with us we're doing right
you've got to pass our laws because the
people want if they say that people
wanted and they don't have anything like
the tea party so that was just one
observation I'd like you to be respond
to and then the other is that the Tea
Party you know is very amorphous there
was no leadership I mean there are tea
party coordinators so it would be very
difficult to have a consensus on on
certain policies and things thank you
yes let me respond especially to your
second point because one danger which
the tea party faces which the Sons of
Liberty didn't face in the late
eighteenth century was the the the way
in which the space and politics has been
has been has been filled in by
organizations and and interests because
government has expanded so much you know
every every professional society every
union and corporation I have to have or
feel like they have to have lobbying
groups in Washington and in the tea
party fate as a as a kind of populist
movement faces that problem that being
caught in institutions who have their
own which have their own agenda
and it's it's harder to maintain your
purity if you want to maintain your
purity as a as a populist movement in
today's Washington and in today's
America that's why something like the
constitutionalist agenda Allah you know
which would of course not couldn't be
the solitary agenda of any political
group you would you'd have to talk about
real you know Paula at the policies Tax
Policy and immigration and you know
everything else of course at the same
time but to make this a necessary though
not sufficient part of of Tea Party
appeals seems to me to give them a kind
of intellectual coherence that might
help them to fight a little bit against
capture by any of the groups that want
to fund and direct and shape their
evolution
the middle of the rotor not really
Frank Fletcher I'll just preface my
comments by saying that before Fidel
Castro became the dictator emeritus of
Cuba he changed the Constitution to say
Cuban socialism could never be repealed
so if the if the left is going to defend
Obamacare might their next project be a
value-added tax will we be able to stop
that and should we have our own project
to undo the decades of really acceptance
and precedent of the commerce clause and
it's its use and interpretation and I
recall that that poor man in the 1930s
was it that he produced wheat and and
and and they said he didn't engage in
interstate commerce but they they said
even his own consumption will somehow
you know affect Wickard V filburn
yes can this be undone I mean I was
listen to her I talked to Roger Pilon
once about that but I don't know how
hopeful it is it would be difficult but
perhaps that's something that people
should begin to think about how might
one go about doing that yes no I think
there's all kinds of creative thinking
that needs to be brought to bear on sort
of a constitutionalist agenda as an
important part of Republicans appeal I
mean it's also one thing to say that
your principles are true and forever
forever true
I mean Jefferson and others made that
claim and it's almost implicit in the
notion of truth too to be eternal or at
least as long as the circumstances
surrounding that truth apply to it or of
that truth but it's something else to
say that a particular set of programs or
Institute or political institutions are
forever
because history is on their side and
they and there's absolutely no human
choice left to the matter and that's I
think what this essentially separates
Jefferson from Castro on that kind of
question thank you